welcome everyone to the smart analytics
roadmap session I'm Stu the husband and
the director of product for smart
analytics at Google cloud data across
organizations is growing and that
organizations need a very strong
analytics platform to leverage this data
create insights and make real-time
decisions on top of this data at Google
Cloud we are a data company we basically
collect massive amounts of data we
leverage our machine learning and AI
capabilities to generate insights from
them and power our products we have more
than nine products we have nine products
that have more than billion users that
use it every day every day at Google
cloud we have also seen conversions of
lot of these technology trends we have
seen organizations are breaking down
data silos between data leaks and data
warehouses as organizations are moving
to crowd they want to be able to
interoperate between all of these data
assets that have been created second
we're seeing organizations focus a lot
more on real-time decision making and
lot of processes historically have been
built for batch processing and this
transition to real-time processing is is
requiring organizations to think about
how do you go and build consolidated
solutions that can run on both real-time
as well as batch data and then finally
analytics and AI merging these concepts
like data scientists are spending 80% in
some studies on on data preparation and
analysts are trying to go ahead and do
predictive analytics on top of data that
they have and convergence of these
different users within organizations use
cases is also becoming a norm now so at
Google cloud our vision is to go ahead
and provide you with an enterprise class
data platform that is proven proven to
be dependable we at Google actually have
services that are built for scale built
for availability so we want to bring
that same kind of rigor to
to our data platform the other thing is
we believe in open and flexible
capabilities we are we are also
leveraging some of the intelligence
capabilities the AI ml embedding it
within our products so we want to
provide you with this end-to-end smart
analytics platform that that allows you
to go ahead and get more value out of
your data so what is the platform entail
you can go ahead and collect massive
amounts of events in real time or in
patch with the platform organizations
like Spotify or collecting events every
time you play a song the event gets
collected across the globe using pub/sub
the process the data through data flow
which is a streaming service that allows
you to go into stream processing as well
as batch processing you could also use
data prop which is managed Hadoop and
spark environment with with similar kind
of datasets and then you can use
bigquery for large-scale analysis in
addition to that we have launched
migration service that allows you to
easily migrate from your traditional
data warehouses to bigquery we launched
in a fusion it's a data integration
service visually you can create data
pipelines end-to-end and then go ahead
and and deploy it on on GCP we went ga
end of last year and we have seen
tremendous interest in this from
customers across the floor data prep is
the data wrangling service it's a
partnership with trifecta it allows you
to go ahead and do zero code data
wrangling or data preparation we are
also going to have a couple of new SKUs
that are being launched or for data prep
as we as we go into into this year the
other thing is also from storage
perspective you can leverage bigquery or
BigTable a lot of organizations use
BigTable as their backbone for or
high-throughput data sets like when you
need it for your e-commerce website and
all and an organization use bigquery for
large large scale analytical data sets
it's it's a
analytical store and then you can use
bigquery for an
with sequel it has various different
capabilities in sequel and then like
things like bi engine which is our
in-memory technology embedded machine
learning so you can create machine
learning models with like just couple of
lines of sequel and then you can also
use spark with the data proc a lot of
organizations like using spark ml for
machine learning models and all you can
do that with data problem and then
finally to activate to take actions on
top of your data you can use a looker or
look at the great addition to our
platform we'll talk more about that
later in the in the presentation
connected sheets you can now leverage
connected sheets like Google sheets to
leverage the power of bigquery on the
backs back-end you can take a petabyte
scale data set and just start analyzing
it with with connected sheets and then
on top of that we launch data catalog
earlier in the year it allows you to go
in and get metadata understanding of
your of your environment you can search
for a data set that you have put some
policies on top of that data and then
composer which is our workflow
orchestration capability which is
managed air flow allows you to do bring
all of these services together so
overall if you look at the platform you
can collect you can process the data you
can store it in various different
platform solutions that we have for
different use cases you can analyze it
at scale and then you can activate on
top of that data with different kind of
fact agents one of the other things we
we were talking about earlier is this
interoperability so at Google Cloud one
of our key value propositions is to go
ahead and have this completely
interoperable environment but you can
have your data in a data warehouse or
indeed a lake or in databases and you
can use the same big query engine to go
ahead and run queries across all of them
even Google sheets then on the other
side if you store your data in bigquery
which is then highly analytical store
you can then use any of the other
engines including like you can use the
bigquery engine but you can also use
fork engine with data from you can use
beam we did of no you can use Klaudia so
all of these different engines
like Aquaman and they seamlessly work on
top of a plane so this interoperability
is one of the key value propositions
that we focused on we've added a lot of
capabilities in last year or so and then
we continue to improve it as we go we
have seen tremendous growth across the
globe every industry every region
organizations like from Home Depot to
AirAsia HSBC ups like you will see
different kind of organizations some of
them like cloud native startups to like
Twitter's and all and to like you know
traditional enterprise organizations
using and using the platform so today as
I talk through the roadmap I want to
take you through four different kinds of
use cases that organizations use of
scenarios one is with modernizing your
data analytics with bigquery data links
with data proc and composer more
responsive businesses with data flow and
observe and then finally enterprise bi
with lucre let's talk about bigquery
bigquery is highly scalable cloud data
warehousing solution we have customers
that have few terabytes to hundreds of
petabytes within bigquery
it's completely serverless you bring
data in loaded and start clearing you
have like you don't have to worry about
machines and operations and
manageability or anything like that it
allows you to do real-time streaming you
can we have customers that are ingesting
tens of millions of events every day
sorry tens of millions of events every
second into bigquery we have embedded
machine learning and then we also enable
insights for everyone with an
organization with with investments they
connected sheets now data and insights
is accessible to everyone one of the
other innovations that we have worked on
is their on the pricing so bigquery is
ten years old in June this year we
became 10 years we pioneered the pricing
model of paper query but over a period
of time organizations have asked for
different options so we launched
bigquery flat rate which is subscription
pricing every month fixed price
that you can go ahead and leverage
bigquery with the consistent price point
we also had a lot of customers asked us
for for this burst per second per minute
billing so that they can bring workloads
that are bursty Monday morning ETL jobs
have to run or or you have Black Friday
event that happens in u.s. so all of
these different kinds of use cases
needed this burst capability the beauty
of three pricing models with big queries
you can actually interchange them you
can basically use all three of them in a
mix-and-match fashion within your
organization and go ahead and leverage
each one of them for different kind of
use cases so you can you can easily mix
and match this let's talk about bigquery
roadmap I'm going to highlight few of
the key things but there is a another
session at the bottom of the screen you
will see these recommendations I have
four different sessions that give you
deep dive into these these specific
areas but let's talk about BI engine and
materialized views always fast always
fresh bigquery ml and data Q&A and Omni
today always fast always fresh this is
our theme around collecting large scale
events in real time we have rebuilt our
whole storage engine to be streaming
first along with that we have
materialized views where what we what
users can do is they can take this data
that's streaming coming in on any batch
data that comes in you can partition and
cluster it so that the queries become
faster but with materialized use views
you can actually pre aggregate and keep
the data sets ready for the use case
that needs the low latency the one of
the best things about materialized views
is as the underneath data changes have
been automatically update your
materialized view you do not have to
worry about like you know running
scheduled jobs and also we will
automatically materialize it second
thing we do is if a query is returned
after or if you have an old query that
doesn't use materialized view but you've
created this materialized view
internally our query engine will read
out the queries to go through
materialized view so so that's a really
good capability so you don't have to
worry about changing all your queries
around and finally big big query bi
engine so bi engine allows you to have
this in memory caching layer on top of
bigquery that gives you subsequent
latency response times on your bi use
cases today it only works the data
studio but later in the year we will
make it available through tobu sequel
which is our internal name for our
sequel capability so any query coming to
bigquery will be able to leverage bi
engine so this will be available through
all the BI tools or JDBC drivers as well
as the queries that you fire it will
give you like really fast response times
on top and we will also support some of
the star schemas for for bi into use
cases and the other thing is nothing
changes on your side right the same
query we will automatically fall down to
whichever layer has the most cash
results for you so if it's bi engine
in-memory caching we will use that if
not we'll fall to materialized view if
not to partition that cluster let's
switch gears talk about bigquery ml
bigquery ml is a embedded machine
learning capability it allows you to
write two lines of code to create
machine learning models and then get
predictions with similar kind of to two
lines of code so we launched this like a
year and a half back and then since then
we have been adding all these different
types of models we have seen tremendous
interest in k-means clustering with my
matrix recommendations or
recommendations for matrix factorization
we have customers who have taken their
historical user data go on ahead and
create clusters based on what type of
users are there and then do product
recommendations to them you'll be using
matrix acquisition in recent times we
have also added a new capabilities where
now you can connect to cloud AI services
and their capabilities like Auto ml
tables now bigquery ml with two lines of
sequel you can leverage auto amend you
can use XG boost from there and use DNN
models with it so we are we are
basically making it
all the different cloud AI capabilities
more accessible through sequel for a big
query and our data analyst community now
we also have the time series forecasting
but the most important thing that we
have added is this interoperability with
with tensorflow
now you can take the model that you
created in bigquery exported in this
tensorflow and then loaded into your
serving platform and make it more
accessible in the real time world to the
other theme we have had is this
democratizing insights with connected
sheets you can take a petabyte scale
table and then have a great
visualization we played out of analysis
with connected sheets or GCB sheets with
data Q&A now you can use natural
language to get your questions answered
so it's basically you just ask the
question get an answer this is going to
free up lot of time for bi teams right
you don't have now create a custom
dashboard or a report for every question
that comes up you can just ask it the
the main thing that we're focused on is
making this available through various
different experiences we do realize
organizations want different experiences
with natural language in many cases it's
all available through an API so
organizations can build their own custom
experiences we will make it available
through Google sheets we will have some
chat BOTS dialog flow integration so all
of these different integrations are
planned to be coming it's all built on
our internal technology called analyzer
there's a great paper on it if you're
interested but this is the same
technology that also powers Google
assistant and various different services
that we have internally it allows us to
go ahead and get like question parsing
intent identification and entity
matching all done automatically are
using the same technology and then the
sequel and how we map it to bigquery is
where here we are innovating so so great
new capability if you are interested now
you should reach out to us so that we
can become
we access the other big area every
organization is in multi color
environment now if not they will be in
in some time to come
few years back that is to always
question which flower why cloud and all
of that now I talked to customers across
the globe most questions most of the
questions that they ask is what are the
key capabilities in which cloud and how
do i leverage them for their use cases
so bigquery Omni is our ability to take
some of our core capabilities with
bigquery and extend them into other
cloud environments so you will get the
same experience you would still go to
the bigquery why you still write the
similar queries you're just now
accessing data on different clouds so
that's one main thing and then finally
leveraging anfos internally so that that
management of the machines and all of
that is not your problem we just do that
behind the scenes the way to think about
this is like we are now saying we are
announcing the availability on Azure in
the early alpha phases where you can
reach out to us and bitching you can
start testing and validations and stuff
like that we will make it available to
organizations in form of beta and all
later in the year and all but but the
way to think about it is it's just
another region so you have the same
control plane same query experience in
bigquery but today you can connect to US
and EU multi region or one of the
regional deployments of bigquery
datasets and now the data in s3 just
becomes another dataset for you to go
and query we will take our compute
engine and run in and it in AWS so you
don't pay any aggress charges back and
forth within that the only time egress
will be involved is when you move that
end result set that you have aggregates
are something that you created if you
want to move it back into TCP then then
egress will be there but otherwise you
don't have to worry about any of that
all that is managed service we take care
of all of that stuff in a place is
available now and I sure will be coming
soon in incoming quarters so let's
switch gears now and and look at the
second topic we covered a bigquery from
an analytic
perspective let's go to data lake side
of things be like you know if you think
about Google cloud some of the largest
data links are running on top of top of
GCE and and like customers like Twitter
and Pandora all of them run landscape
clusters on earth and on us and the
reason is it's super fast and secure
it's managed and it's cost-effective for
for organizations and we do support
manage experience around various
different Apache projects like spark and
and Hadoop and Scala and presto and and
druid and and just pick one like it
enable you to run Ranger all of that and
also we have managed air flow which is
available as composer service that is
they're there today I wanted to talk
about few key roadmap items in this area
one is enterprise notebooks second is
data proc meta store and then analytics
func abilities again more details in
other session we launched our cloudy I
notebooks in in recent past right it's
available organizations are using it
across the board you can have your
personal notebook you can create a team
notebook with kubernetes back-back
environment but what we have launched
now it's in beta that's available is
that's not analytics framework and what
that is is we are bringing all the big
data capabilities big data services
behind the same boundary i notebooks
environment and enabling you to run this
on top of a data processor so basically
large-scale spawn chops can now run on
top of top of it you just go and create
a notebook from data prop environment
and then it's available and then you
also have the beam notebook and it also
connects with like bigquery data flow
data prop all of these engines become
accessible to you from the same
framework really powerful really looking
forward to enabling these data scientist
across the globe to leverage this new
environment that's available the next
topic I'm going to talk about is manage
data meta store or high - or lot of
organizations have told us managing a
high - store is painful
we should just have a managed version of
it that's exactly what we're doing it's
going to be completely integrated with
our security capability monitoring and
monitoring capability in Google Cloud it
will support all the major their
security capabilities that organizations
need over time we will enable all of
that stuff so so that is there then you
will be able to go ahead and scale out
over time and all of that so it's it's
available in beta this year and so I
would highly recommend using this if
you're running any kind of a Hadoop
environment on top of Hadoop or spark
environment in in Google Cloud you
should use the managed meta store now
now finally I'm super excited about this
transition from yarn to kubernetes in in
the in the Big Data world and we
pioneered some of it with with a launch
of Sparkle kubernetes and we we believe
that this is the best next step for for
open source community to adopt
kubernetes and so right now we have
spark on kubernetes available we are
looking at other options like like flink
and entresto but but this is this is a
great way of running
arc environment where where kubernetes
becomes the backbone for a management
you know one of the other things this
enables is for you to now run spark jobs
on top of bigquery earlier I talked
about how bigquery enables you to have
the analytical storage accessible from a
data proc and beam with this now you can
have spark on kubernetes connected to
bigquery and you can run large-scale
spark ml jobs or or various different
kinds of aggregates that you may want to
run outside of bigquery sequence so
great way of doing that with that let me
actually switch gears and talk about the
next topic that we have which is around
running building more responsive
businesses with with real-time
environment right so we covered bigquery
analytical count data warehousing or we
covered data leaks now let's talk about
now dataflow and of some
if you look at real-time is becoming
really critical there's a standard
pattern to ingest large scale events you
want to transform them and you want to
analyze and serve them later and so the
pattern normally in GCP the way it works
is you use pops up for for large-scale
connection you can always use cough calm
confident as a good managed service of
that you can transform and
transformations normally dataflow is the
best engine I think across all clouds or
for running large scale stream
processing and then you can read and
also your spa if you wanted to and then
for analyzing and storing later you can
use cloud ml you can use bigquery you
can use BigTable there are a lot of
different options there in the in the
roadmap side I wanted to highlight few
of the key things here one was pops of
light dataflow sequel making it easy to
get started with streaming the
pipeline's
observability and manageability and of
course streaming predictions again more
details and another session in 101 if
you think about collection of events
pops up is an amazing global service as
I said Spotify uses it large-scale
organizations are using it but we have
seen adoption of lot of like you know
do-it-yourself messaging platforms on
GCP and not of organizations have said
hey we want a lower cost option we want
something to get started in smaller
teams departmental use cases and then
box of light is exactly for that it's
the zonal service it's super low cost so
that organizations can get started they
don't have to manage their
infrastructure fully managed really low
price and low cost offering I would
actually challenge you to compare your
do-it-yourself costs against up sublight
and I think up some light will become
much more compelling for you in even
those scenarios it's a zonal service so
keep that let you know you should have
that in your failover scenarios and
stuff like that think through what you
ibly and then it will integrate with
dataflow and other services like cloud
functions and all natively
out of the box the other thing I want to
highlight today is data flow sequel we
want to make building streaming pipeline
super easy data flow sequel allows you
to write sequel statements to create
complex pipelines you use the same big
query experience for writing sequel it's
the same bigquery UI and some of the
innovation that we've done in bigquery
UI with multi tabs and all I'm super
excited about that too but you can just
write a sequel statement and create the
whole pipeline and we take care of all
of the creation management all of that
after that the thing that it's available
today is with Aqsa as well as bigquery
we're going to add tasks we are going to
add a big table and cloud sequel in
addition to those and then we also are
looking at UVs and enabling UDF's
creating pipelines making it easy is
great but a lot of organizations want us
to go ahead and make manageability and
like an operational management of these
pipelines really easy so we just
launched our approach observability
dashboards early in the year manage
pipelines is coming - which allows you
to take any pipeline go dig deeper into
individual steps what happened and what
the bottleneck was and how do you
resolve the bottom so so a lot of that
stuff is is is getting better and better
over time finally the two of the key
strengths in google cloud is streaming
and AI services which is machine
learning in AI and be a bringing both of
them together with dataflow enabling
various different integrations with
cloudy i api's and services integration
with tensor flow extended now you can
build streaming pipelines which
basically span from Alec large amount of
events go ahead and transform them do
the prediction in real time and then go
ahead and serve it from a serving layer
we are taking not just topping and just
based integrations we are going to have
templatized solutions like anomaly
detection where you can take
and customize it for your industry you
use case and then go ahead and use it
we've seen anomaly detection being used
for fraud detection in financial
services or e-commerce sites we have
seen that in network anomaly detection
in in telecom and all of that so so
these standardized patterns and
templates are going to help
organizations to adopt it faster finally
we are also going to enable GPUs and
Tipu's through dataflow pipelines this
has been one of the the most asked for
capabilities so you will have that
ability to so we covered bigquery the
data warehousing we covered data links
we covered streaming analytics let's
switch gears to enterprise bi and data
applications so looker now is part of
Google from family it's a great data
platform that that's available it
basically look at is based on this
amazing semantic modeling layer it
allows you to define your common
understanding of your metrics within the
organization and this is one of the
biggest pain points for most of our
customers they basically have different
like you know self-service bi enabled
everybody to define their own dashboards
but also everybody to have their own
definition of common of their metrics so
with looker you basically define your
common metrics this allows organizations
to rally behind the common understanding
of these key metrics it also has this bi
capably me with great visualizations
great tooling for your dashboards and
reports and also that's always there it
another thing it allows you to lose
everything in looker is an API so you
can build your own custom applications
and custom use cases and both flows on
top of Roper some of the organization
using local rod-like you can't even see
anything in looker there it's just an
API headless bi platform that you can go
ahead and do whatever you guys you want
on top of it and then we've seen lot of
organizations use embedded now looker
where we look at simple
other applications it works with more
than 55 different kind of sequel
dialects means different databases and
data warehouses in the world including
bigquery and and some of the other cloud
providers today there's a little long
list of capabilities we are adding with
lucre there is a great session that that
will go into deep dive into that but
today I wanted to highlight the three
key capabilities that that we are
enabling looker-on GCP integration with
the BI engine and then instant
exploration so first of all making
looker available in the cloud console in
GCP is one of our big priorities this
year what that will enable you to do is
with one-click get access to looker get
started and and leverage the product but
one of the most important things is we
are also focusing on all the key
security horizontals that that you all
care about play you won't see Mac and
you want like a VP CSE all of those
different kind of horizontals then we'll
come over time but but that that's part
of being a Google service where we're
focused on that the second thing is
better integration with bigquery is of
course one of our priorities the
bigquery plus lucre is is an amazing
combination like there's unlimited scale
on one side and then create visual
capabilities but common API is that you
can use semantic modeling layer it's
really good story together and with bi
engine or in memory caching layer you
can now start bringing these two
together and get sub-second latencies on
most of your dashboarding and and
reporting use cases on different
visualizations you want to go better
finally in looker you do have to start
with a model define it in look ml and we
wanted to make it very easy for
organizations and analysts
in organizations to go from bigquery and
start using the power of recur and
basically what you will be able to do
with the instant Explorer exploration
capability is you can write a query in
bigquery why with one click you can get
into which
with lucre you will be able to put an ad
calculated fields you can share those
visualizations with your peers within
the organization and then finally when
you are ready to go to this higher level
capability with enterprise capability
with the govern bi and have this
modeling layer that you want to
customize then you can go ahead and
upgrade to that but this starting off
and getting started with lucre with
bigquery is going to become super simple
the few clicks you will be able to go to
that now we covered a lot of stuff today
across cloud data warehousing data lakes
streaming analytics as well as
Enterprise bi and data applications we
have tons of more stuff coming with a
lot of details that we have across
across the portfolio in the last few
years we will be leaders in every every
report that's come out from analysts
Forrester this is a good one where for
20/20 data management and analytics wave
we were the leader
same thing with national reports that
have come out and they will look and can
you focusing on enhancing our products
getting feedback from you making sure
that that we are working on the right
priorities there are also a lot of other
sessions that the team is doing that you
can get more deep dive across different
aspects of the products and different
capabilities that we have we have 30
plus additional sessions with customer
use cases how our customers and
organizations are using the platform so
I will highly recommend viewing all of
all of those and finally thank you for
your time today
really appreciate the listening tour our
roadmap force mathematics thank you